γιατί πράγματα μήνμε γιατί τημές μιλουμε γιατί υπηρεσίες εκτώστου να θακαρισμια εταιρα είναι ανάλογα με
το το ίδος συαδιά θέλω ένα όλοπάο να πτο παραδώσως στην πόρτα μο και να
τος ληρώσω στην κύπρωενδεν έχουμε καλι τεό σας λέω όμως υπήρχαν περιπτώσεισε όπου μερική υπαράγγειλα
να αρκωτικά με σκοπό να το παραδοθεί στην κύπρον τους έχουμε εντοπίσει αυτούς και αυτού
είχαμε και τις υπιτυχίες με τηικάν έχουμεάμε στην και συνεχή συνεργασία και γι αυτό νεντοπίσαμε
και μπορεί να παραγγείλουν ποραδή μοσχάρι κάποιον παέπτον με κάποια εξακτήματα να μπορεί α παραγγείλουσν
ότι δήποτε ότι δήποτε κή μπορεν αγοράσουν να πακέττον με παιδική μπορώ νο γραφείαν πραη
μουσχάρι μπορεί να αγοράσουν εξαυτάτα από το ίδος εξατάτ από το ίδος τη τη ζητούμε
μια πλή παραδημοσιχάρη τίτοσατα ηλαδή είναι μια συνεχούμε τη τιαποστολή μηνιγμάτον προς μια εταιρεία ανα
μην αντεξιογ στοσείδα μια σεταιρεία και να καταρεύψει η λόγο τουυπερπολικού ογκουδεδομένο που τέλουμε τημάτων
που στέλλουμε δευτυχις δηπολλά χίλια επροπαραγμασχάρι εξατάτε από το είδο οη υπηρεσίας που θέλουμε να
αποκτήσουμε υπάρχουν του εξωταρικό νοόμως περιλκ επρεκτώτι που γοράζουν πλισμό ναι ογοράζουνν δε αφορά άλλα
πράγματα υπάρχουνε αυτά ταυράγματα θα παραγολουθούμενος και αστηνομία τα αυτό χρονά δεν είμαυτε το σκοτάα
δηπαρόλουμε τ αρκουεπ δεν είμαστε τον σκοτάδη έχουμεκακυπριακαί στυνομία απού το θέσατε οι κυπρία και
αστνομία δεν είχε της πληροφορίας από τις ξένες υπηρεσίες σύχ να ακούμε μετά από πληροφορεία
ξένεις υπηρεσίας πήγαμε κχτηρίσαμε την πόρτα συλλάβα με τον τάδδεν είχε νααυτές τές ι πληροφορίας
θα μπορούσε ανα λιτουργής ει μόνητης φυσικάέχει τιδηνάτα ότε τα έχετε να αλλά